what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have a lot of news to go over
including of course news about our main
man spider-man we have some new promo
art to go over and there are some
supposed leaked photos going around that
state that they could be recreating an
iconic meme so of course we have to talk
about that and some news about the
hawkeye trailer it looks like things are
getting pretty serious for hawkeye which
is good because it's only coming in a
few months we're getting it in november
so that trailer should be hitting us
pretty soon and today we actually have
some events that lead us to believe that
yes it is indeed going to be soon and
last but not least we have some
daredevil in the mcu news and no not
simply just matt murdock appearing in
spiderman no way home not in his
daredevil outfit but we have news about
him possibly getting his own show and
him cameoing in other shows and movies
until then like i said we have a lot to
break down today so let's dive right
into it but if you're new be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu videos so let's first talk
about a leaked photo that is going
around i personally can't show it
because it has been getting taken down
off of some platforms and in case it is
real and something that the studio
doesn't want people to see i won't post
it because i don't want anything to
happen to my channel but basically what
it is is just a single spider-man
pointing i will retweet it on my twitter
so if you want to find it check out my
twitter link in the description but like
i said basically it is spider-man
pointing and what this is supposed to be
according to the person who leaked it is
the iconic meme of the three spider-man
pointing to each other when they see
each other for the very first time now
of course this started off as just two
spider-men but obviously since there are
going to be three in this film the meme
has changed to the three of them now i
will state i don't know the validity of
this like i said i don't know if it's
real or fake apparently there was a fake
one out there with toby maguire
spider-man laying on the ground
according to the poster that one wasn't
real but this one is real i will say
whether or not this photo is real or not
as most of you know i firmly believe
that the three spider-men are going to
be in this film i've been told it by a
bunch of different sources if they're
not in the film i will be completely
shocked but i believe they will be and i
also believe that if we are getting a
movie with all of them together and they
don't recreate this meme i think it
would be an incredibly large missed
opportunity perhaps one of the biggest
missed opportunities ever in fact if
they just showed us a trailer of the
three spider-man pointing at each other
for like two seconds i'm sure that would
completely break all records there are
four trailers so i am hoping that this
photo is real and that the three
spider-man are actually pointing to each
other during this scene and like i said
we do have some new promotional art
today showing spidey's red and black
suit his new black and gold suit and his
new iron spider suit now the iron spider
suit that we saw in the teaser trailer i
firmly believe is edited we saw the old
iron spider suit i believe that he is
going to be getting a new iron spider
suit based off of the promo art that
we've seen but this is simply some
clever trailer editing marvel is known
to do this remember how the hulk ran
with the avengers in the infinity war oh
wait he didn't but the trailer led us to
believe otherwise i believe this to be
somewhat of the same case and i also
believe that we've seen the other
spider-man in the trailer they've simply
been edited out and the same with the
villains they're there they're just
edited out and i think there's been a
lot of proof for this but anyways the
thing that i'm actually most excited for
is this black and gold suit based off of
everything that we know this is actually
going to be a magical suit that dr
strange enchants now what magical
abilities is the suit actually going to
have well we're not really sure yet it
could make his web stronger which would
be pretty cool it could give him the
ability to shoot some type of magical
webs out in sort of a shot like motion
instead of a swinging the web and
holding on to it but regardless whatever
it is i am super excited to see what
this new suit and the other new suits
can do especially if they're going to be
enchanted by dr strange's magic and now
let's talk about hawkeye a lot of people
are really excited about the hawkeye
series coming to disney plus in november
and since i do a lot of trailer updates
a lot of people have been asking about
the hawkeye trailer and i try not to
typically say anything unless something
actually happens and it looks like we do
have something that is kind of happening
the official twitter page for the
hawkeye series was deactivated some time
ago but recently it was reactivated and
when it was reactivated haley steinfeld
also posted this to her instagram story
simply just a purple background now this
obviously has to do with hawkeye of
course she is playing kate bishop and
we've already seen plenty of pictures of
her in her outfit of kate bishop and
it's purple it's pretty much this exact
purple so right now there is life as
i'll call it with the hawkeye series
there's movement the official twitter
account for the hawkeye series has been
reactivated after being deactivated and
now haley steinfeld is teasing something
herself so something's brewing and it's
most likely the teaser trailer now when
can we actually expect to get the teaser
probably next month in september which
we only really have two days left in
august anyways but if they do it in late
september that'll kind of do two things
one it'll put the teaser out two months
before the series comes out which is
actually kind of late but it will also
give shanghai some time in the theaters
because the studio isn't really going to
want to take focus away from shanghai
when it first releases i mean every day
so far for like the past week and a half
we've gotten a new tv spot for shanxi
and if you can go see it go see it i
highly recommend the movie it is one of
my favorite marvel movies and again i
don't think marvel studios and disney
are going to want to take focus off that
on its first week of release so i would
probably guess that it's going to be a
late september release for the hawkeye
trailer there have been rumors not
reports but rumors unconfirmed that it
could air at the emmys it could also air
with miss marvel that is the rumor going
around right now marvel has been known
to drop big trailers during big events
if you've ever seen a super bowl in the
past few years you've seen something
from marvel and the emmys right now fall
on september 19th which is right around
when i expect them to kind of drop the
trailer and it's enough time since
chongqi's release to not really take any
focus away from it and since it's the
emmys a lot of people will be watching
so it'll get a lot of exposure so it
should be coming pretty soon but i
should also add that it could come
before this haley steinfeld is teasing
this on her instagram which means it
could actually be right around the
corner and the account is active again
which means it's going to start tweeting
again so i'd keep an eye out for it and
of course if i hear anything i'll be
sure to do an update now the last thing
i want to talk about is something pretty
cool that i know a lot of daredevil fans
are going to be really excited for and
really just defender fans in general if
you're a fan of the marvel netflix
series this is some good news the
account main middleman on twitter who
has been pretty accurate with a lot of
their news recently a lot of scoops
proven true it said that they have heard
that a daredevil centered series
presumably for disney plus is being
talked about right now however whether
this series does come to fruition or not
and does actually become a thing
daredevil is set to appear in other
films and tv shows before getting his
own now we've obviously heard the report
about him appearing in spider-man no way
home and it looks like we may have
spotted him in the trailer which we'll
have to see during spider-man no way
home but this account also states that
this is going to happen with some of the
other marvel netflix series leading
characters as well i'm assuming jessica
jones iron fist luke cage pretty much
all of the defenders we've also already
heard that kingpin is indeed going to be
in the echo series that is coming to
disney plus and we could be getting some
other characters such as the punisher
this account states that other things
being discussed at this point are
whether they will be projects developed
outside of disney plus focusing on
productions that are besides pg-13
meaning rated r if they do this that
means they could do a rated r punisher
which i think a lot of fans would enjoy
obviously deadpool 3 is coming and
everybody wants it to be rated r to keep
the same deadpool that we know from the
fox universe he is kind of literally the
only good thing to come from the fox
universe i do love the original three
x-men and logan but recently you know
i'm really glad that the x-men are now
in disney and marvel's hands but with
other groups like the midnight suns
hopefully coming a rated r section for
all of these new marvel shows would
actually be pretty good we don't really
want some of these characters watered
down if they can do it in a pg-13 manner
like they do venom and carnage cool but
the punisher isn't really a pg-13
character but the good underlying news
is that it looks like marvel studios
could be considering bringing some of
these netflix characters back and
putting them in the mcu something that i
know a lot of fans will be really really
happy about myself included and it does
look like that if they do this they are
going to be keeping the same actors and
actresses so we have a lot to look
forward to in the mcu things are already
exciting as it is right now and i think
they're just going to continue to get
more and more exciting so if you want to
stay up to date on everything happening
in the mcu be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you can stay
up to date be sure to leave your
comments in the comment section down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you